こんにちははじめ社長です
なんか
別に俺も日本では何かあったっちゃったなって感じなんですけども
ここまで分かりやすいのは初めてだなって感じです僕の右でご覧ください
わかりますかねこれではから人おらんでしょ cocco
すごいんですよこれ明らかにながヤバイのができるというここに水にめちゃくちゃって
これができてるんですよどう見てもヤバイ
こっちゃ
何もないんですけどこっち
tan
はいへっいや笑い事じゃないんですあのこれ何かと言いますとまだ何かわかんないん
ですけども
一般的にを入れるガングリオンというものでございますがまぁ名前だけ聞くという番組
内でかっこいいんですけどこれで着ると結構多いらしいんですけどたまにナイフかな体
にぼこってなんかぜひ見たいのでてるのってさワールドなぜ b 場みたいな補任胸し
てる感じなんですよねいやんですごい気味
しちゃって一角を指でぶっ潰そうとのターン数が違う埋没ブレなくてどうしようと一周
考えちゃっているというところでございますそもそもガングリオンとは玩具ディオンと
は中にゼリーのような物質の詰まっている腫瘍であるでき se 場所としてばて特に
手首の甲側なんつってこれじゃあも確定者手首の甲側にできましてですね大きな人に
よってまちまちで行
3つほどの大きさからピンポン何のような大きさの瞳て硬さもなんかバラバラなんだむ
肖像な場合が多いんですけどもうなんか神経が通ってる近くにあるとしびれたり痛みと
が感覚麻痺とません
俺じゃあねこれすごいダメッってこれがんげじょんだぞともわからないけどね勝手には
玩具になって君に話進めているんですけどやっぱなんかちゃんと病院行った方がいいよ
ということも書いてありますね
そんな彼に前に入ってるんだって
困ってるんでしょ別に気にしなきゃいいんだとキッズできんですけどもなんか気になっ
ちゃうよちょっと言いたいんですよねピリピリしてすごいなかやんでええ
場合によっては手術をして玩具にを摘出することもあるってもしやなぁ
ね超やべーじゃん早めに富んだいたが悪化する可能性もあるらしいんでちょっとちょっ
てまっすぐようにすぐ病院すぐ病院
周回するよあっよねちょっと症状
4日ですねての幸運の症状なんですけど
で玩具によっていうんですかねなんかちょっとズルいショップのができた
まずねちょっとピリピリ痛みポイント続いてて
なんか病院に行くと何かあったりしますかあのー
原料
いたりとかっていうより良いもありますがつい
dje 3型の問題になるあったのですね
感じますちょっと京都カテイ診察にお答えしてもよろしいでしょうか
ni
あは感じではもう向かわせていただきます
はいお願いいたします
ほい
行ってきます
っていうわけで病院から帰ってきましたーー
[音楽]
を治療してきましたいやもうねぇあの
痛かった結構古いほど痛かったです
結果から言いますとあの元レビューんでしたねどういう治療をさがと言いますとあの
端的に言うと注射器ぶっさして玩具リオ全体初宇宙って引っ張ったんですけども抜く
瞬間位置を取れたんでぜひあのか
くださいどうぞ
ええええ
イケてるッ
ございません
至ります
をも大丈夫ですはぁ
対応お茶になりましたでしょうかびっくりするぐらい痛かったですねほんとにマジでい
ただった
やっぱなぜこの6区からさー針がめっちゃ太いわけですよ
よく部東の端注射器ぶっ刺されてこっ中てゼリー情熱抜かれてめっちゃ臭いたかったん
ですけども一応これで ok ということですねこれ言語のようなんですけど
西でよろしくで感じつからできる
パターンとその筋肉品数字県から出来る方がいらっしゃって動画関節じゃなくて県から
出てるパターンだったらしいんですよで賢者ができてる奴って放置でなお d やすい
パンて破裂しなを降らすんです呼ぶそうですけど自然放鳥治りませんですけどもなんか
ちょっとエヴァ痛みがあったんでお医者さんと相談して後彼も自然放置なんて
とりあえず注射器でもう
抜いといた方がいいんじゃないかという
マでイカせていただきましたなんか結構
できる人が多いらしいダメかな皆さんも経験ある方はいらっしゃると思うんですよ突然
体にぷくってなかってきたなんか課題のできたとか結果的にいたそれそんなに何か君
することでもない見たくて放置でもいいし痛みが伴ったりいえば見た目でちょっと
になっちゃうなんて人はぜひどうぞ
山に行ったり力技ね破壊することができるんですねなんか病院だとこう疲れて押し込ん
でバーンて晴れてたシェルと僕もあるんですけど
こういった to the に取るのもまた作戦かなということでぜひ参考にしてみて
くださいあなた駐車バッチコリーた後ですねあでも良かったこれで左右対称に入られた
んであの結果的にすぐにいってこと良かったのかなと思いますやもうあの
ブーブーと思ったら to do
あっはーる elh
[音楽]
goo
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
me
[音楽]